[Musik]
[Applaus]
grüß gott meine leben voll aber ich
hoffe natürlich tut es gut gehen
ich dachte die österreicher unter dem
die denken sich gerade so leute was gehe
ich hoffe natürlich gibt es gut dass auf
jeden fall schon mal decken dann nach
oben da ich habe keine ahnung ob ich das
jetzt hier wirklich verwendet weil
gerade erst aufgestanden
das kann man auch glaube ich sehen auf
jeden fall bin ich ja gerade in
österreich im skiurlaub und ich habe mir
gedacht wann passt diese technik besser
als sie hat ich habe in letzter zeit
öfter talent ist gemacht zum beispiel 24
stunden den knopf zum beispiel 24
stunden autobahnraststätte heute machen
wir das ganze mal mit einer nationalität
und zwar 24 stunden lang nur richtig 24
schon österreichisches essen und sie ist
krank ich würde sagen muss man ja nicht
viel zu erklären schreibt mir gerne
weitere idee in die kommentare für
weiteren stellen
vielleicht irgendwelche nationalitäten
oder so und am wegen jetzt mal runter
zum frühstück das soweit ich weiss nicht
österreich ist richtig also leute das
hier ist das frühstück zum beispiel
hier gibt es dann brot und so und hier
haben wir noch so müsli joghurt getränke
und frisch gepressten aus
[Musik]
so leute wieder davon frühstück ich
wollte das so leute wieder davon
frühstück ich wollte da jetzt nicht
zuviel film einfach weiter so viele
leute sind und so und wir sind hier auch
im hotel müsst ihr verstehen aber jetzt
geht es weiter heißt ich muss auch noch
dazu sagen ich habe vor auch mal ein
bisschen google so wirklich typisch
österreichisch frühstück gibt es ja gar
nicht also das war das frühstück was die
hier im hotel haben das gibt es
natürlich auch so ähnlich in deutschland
ganz klar jetzt geht's allerdings los
auf die piste hier haben wir das ganze
skigebiet kann ich euch ja gerne mal
kurz zeigen hier oben ist ein berg dann
ist da noch einer da und da also hinter
dem haus so und wir fahren häufig
irgendwo dahin das hier ist aber so das
standardwerk wo wir sonst eigentlich
fast immer fahren auf jeden fall gehen
wir mittags natürlich auch eine hütte
also so eine skihütte und da kann man
dann sehr viel essen auswählen bin ich
mal gespannt was es heute mittag für
mich gibt und heute haben dann natürlich
noch und jetzt muss ich mich nicht
umziehen und dann geht es auch schon los
ich habe brocken ich zeige euch gerne
auch mal ein bisschen wie skifahren wenn
euch das interessiert jetzt ein kleiner
tages blog wir sehen uns bis gleich so
läuft das hier ist mein ski outfit könnt
ihr sehr gern mal in den kommentar von
eins bis zehn minuten
und jetzt geht's los ihr anziehen und
ich habe bock
[Musik]
also leute ja ich bin jetzt hier schon
auf der ersten piste ich würde ich das
kurz mal zeigen weil das sie wirklich
echt geil aussieht hier sogar noch ein
bisschen tiefschnee und dann geht es
hier runter hat man auch eine geile
aussicht ist natürlich auch ein bisschen
schwieriger zu fahren weil die nicht
präpariert ist ich habe weiter keine
kurven dabei sonst würde ich das film
aber ihr werdet sehen wenn dieses video
und dann kommt bin ich wohl unten
angekommen also letztlich haben wir auch
wieder einen genialen ausblick wir waren
gerade noch kurz hier auf dieser
schritte wollte ich mal kurz auf film
vor der zoom bei dieser kamera so lahm
rät ihr da irgendwas da hinten sieht man
ein paar berge so heute verteilt würde
das nicht so scheiße auch sehr auf jeden
fall ist jetzt mittagspause angesagt
hier in die leute hinter mir
und ja mal schauen was es gibt hier
werfe ich kann dieses skigebiet
pilleneinnahme kommentare wer schon hier
war
[Musik]
ich nehme aber den kaiser spa mit man
muss genau und geliefert so dass hier
ein ski wasser
[Musik]
leute wieder zurück im hotel ich habe
mir hier in leichten sonnenbrand geholt
wahrheit allerdings auf sehr sonnig mir
ist aufgefallen ich habe noch gar keine
mühe gemacht aber ist auch weniger
spektakulär wir haben hier den eingang
das bad hat man schon gesehen jetzt
klopft ist dann ist hier das bett hinter
mir noch nicht friegel und der fernseher
und hier dann einfach noch so ein
bisschen das ist sehr sehr unaufgeräumt
deswegen gehen wir einfach mal raus hier
ist der balkon habe ich glaube ich heute
morgen schon gezeigt und dann hat man
hier diese wunderschöne aussicht ja ich
jetzt erst mal schwimmen und vorher kann
ich nochmal ein abendessen bestellen was
ich dann heute abend essen möchte und
das soll natürlich typisch ist reichlich
sein glaube ich ne ich nehme euch
einfach mit wir sehen uns dann gleich
und ja bis gleich
jetzt geht's in den saunabereich und
dann ist hier auf einmal so eine ecke wo
man sich noch was zu trinken machen kann
zumindest war das mal so
[Musik]
leute gebt euch einfach mal einen
krassen sonnenbad auf der nase hat das
schon gesehen ich sehe aus wie gut das
orientiert oder 12 auf jeden fall geht
es ans essen leute ich nehme euch mit
manchmal mal gespannt so hier haben wir
die vorspeise das hier finde ich immer
sehr lecker aber ist natürlich nur
vorspeise
[Musik]
nochmal jetzt ein foto mit uns ist das
cool
die kamera läuft die ganze zeit sagen du
kannst stopp machen
[Musik]
leute was gedacht ich hab gerade schon
das video geschnitten und mit auge
fallen ich hab da überhaupt kein ende
gefunden oder halt gar kein ende gemacht
deswegen müssen wir das jetzt noch im
nachhinein machen weil es war ja auch
mal wieder eine 24h challenge wo sich
schon lohnt damals die kalorien zu
berechnen und zu schauen wie viel
kalorien waren es jetzt eigentlich
natürlich ist ganz klar ich denke mal
die meisten österreich braucht viele
österreichische zuschauer ihr könnt ja
gern mal kommentare schreiben ernähren
sich jetzt nicht jeden tag so wie ich
weil ja ist ja schon immer ungesund dann
so einen kaiserschmarrn und wiener
schnitzel auch wenn es wirklich sehr
sehr lecker ist also ich esse sehr gerne
so österreichische spezialitäten wobei
man sich ja auch bei manchen sachen irrt
die kommen dann gar nicht ja aber ich
meine kaiserschmarren wiener schnitzel
wird es nicht viel falsch gemacht
hier geht gerade die sonne unter sieht
so aus und wir machen jetzt mal eben
noch noch recht nun eine trockene nase
immer nicht mehr gewonnen
kaiserschmarrn 232 kalorien pro 100
gramm ich würde sagen dass müssten
ungefähr 400 gramm gebeten sein sagen
wir mal 380 ich hab den ja nicht mal
ganz geschafft muss ein wiener schnitzel
habe ich im internet somit ungefähr 900
kalorien gefunden also mit einer großen
portion com ist aber das hilft
vielleicht lässt und auch diese tipps
alles mögliche tipps okay da sind wir
schon mal bei 1781 dann kommt noch das
she was dazu habe das schon mal probiert
ski besser schmeckt eigentlich ganz geil
wenn man wenn man so richtig durst hat
und noch mal 200 kalorien für die cola
das frühstück nicht zu vergessen
was soll das denn heißen sie sagt klaus
winter und deswegen hast du so einen
bierbauch sagen wir das brötchen somit
120 kalorien
also wir sind auf jeden fall ja es ist
wieder schwierig zu bestimmen
ich hatte dann auch noch eine müsli
schale ich weiß gar nicht was ich
morgens alles gegessen habe und hatte
auch noch so ein kuchen bei den ist hier
immer nachmittags gibt den habe ich
glaube ich gar nicht gefilmt also ich
würde mal sagen wir sind auf jeden fall
bei über 2500 kalorien was schon mehr
ist als ich sonst brauche also mir war
diesmal auf jeden fall klar dass es vier
wird weiter so 500 ist schon ne menge
aber man darf auch auf keinen fall
vergessen ich bin gestern sechs stunden
am stück ski gefahren mit ungefähr 350
pause und dafür braucht man ja auch
einiges deswegen würde ich sagen dass es
an sich sogar voll in ordnung geht
und ja man braucht ja irgendwie die
power ansonsten würde ich sagen das war
es eigentlich mit diesem video wenn es
euch gefeiert das mir sehr gerne daumen
nach oben da ihr habt glaube ich auch
den sturz gesehen ich gestern eingelegt
haben vorgestern habe ich nicht richtig
umgesetzt habe mir wären wir sehr gerne
weitere ideen für 24 stunden service in
die kommentare
ich bin gespannt auch gerne mal so
nationalitäten wenn ihr irgendwelche
ausländischen wurzeln haben oder so
kommentiert die mal was so die typischen
gerichte sind und das was von mir
wir sehen uns haut rein steckt auf jeden
fall mein instagram account ab und ja
sonntag bin ich wieder in deutschland